E
FEDERAL RESERVE AS A WAY TO BEAT
BACK INFLATION.
>> ALEXANDRA, THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN JOE CONCHA,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR
OF THE BOOK THAT BEGINS WITH
"COME ON, MAN!"
THE REST OF THE TITLE IS LONG.
JOE, WOULD DEMS DO BETTER IN THE
MIDTERMS IF, I DON'T KNOW,
JOE BIDEN SAID HE'S DRAGGING
DOWN THE PARTY AND HE'S OUT,
JUST GOING TO SPEND THE REST OF
THE PRESIDENCY BEGINNING TODAY
HANGING OUT IN DELAWARE?
>> THAT'S AN INTERESTING
SCENARIO.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A WHITE
FLAG OF SURRENDER, TODD, SO HE'S
NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING THAT
WOULD THEN MAKE THE NEWS CYCLE
ALL ABOUT HOW JOE BIDEN ISN'T
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN.
IT'LL LOOK LIKE THEY ARE SAYING
THEY ARE DEFEATED, DON'T BOTHER
VOTING FOR US.
BUT I DON'T THINK HE RUNS IN
2024.
I JUST THINK THAT ANNOUNCEMENT
COMES AFTER THE MIDTERMS,
PROBABLY SOMETIME IN EARLY 2023.
BUT WHEN SEVEN IN TEN VOTERS
BELIEVE THE COUNTRY IS HEADED IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION, WHEN A
SOLID MAJORITY OF DEMOCRATS
DON'T WANT A JOE BIDEN SEQUEL
AND DON'T WANT HIM TO SEEK A
SECOND TERM, THE LAST THING
CANDIDATES LIKE TIM RYAN WANT IN
SWING STATES LIKE OHIO IS TO
CREATE AN EASY CAMPAIGN AD, AND
APPEAR WITH A PRESIDENT
RESPONSIBLE FOR 40-YEAR HIGH
INFLATION, SOARING GAS PRICES
LIKE YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT,
AND A WIDE OPEN BORDER, ASHLEY.
>> JOE, THIS IS A REAL KICKER.
THAT BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
PAYING $265,000 A YEAR TO STAFF
MEMBERS WHOSE JOB IS TO DEFLECT
ENTER STORIES, AND
REPUBLICAN-LED INVESTIGATIONS.
THE DEPUTY COUNSEL TO THE
PRESIDENT IS BEING PAID $155,000
TO OVERSEE RESPONSES TO
SUBPOENAS AND OVERSIGHT EFFORTS,
WHILE THE SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO
THE PRESIDENT IS PAID $110,000
ON RESPONDING TO CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATIONS.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT ONE OF THESE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY WORKED ON VP HARRIS'
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, AND WE
ALL KNOW HOW THAT TURNED OUT.
WITH EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED
LAST WEEK, WITH ALL OF THIS
IMMINENT CHANCE OF HUNTER BIDEN
BEING POTENTIALLY CHARGED, THEY
MIGHT HAVE THEIR HANDS FULL.
>> WOW.
THE PERSON WHO WORKED ON
KAMALA HARRIS' 2020 CAMPAIGN?
IT'S FUNNY THEY CALL IT THE 2020
CAMPAIGN WHEN SHE DIDN'T EVEN
GET THE 2020.
SHE DROPPED OUT IN
DECEMBER 2019.
AND THIS IS SOMEONE SEEN AS ONE
OF THE FAVORITES GOING IN.
BUT IN ADMINISTRATION BUT ONCE
CREATED THE DISINFORMATION
GOVERNANCE PORT IS NOW PAYING
PEOPLE TO TRY TO SQUASH A STORY
THAT ISN'T REMOTELY GOING AWAY?
I MEAN, SHUT THE FRONT DOOR,
RIGHT?
WE SEEN THIS IN OCTOBER 2021
HIGHLY PLACED ACTIVISTS AT
FACEBOOK AND TWITTER SUPPRESSED
AND CENSORED THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY WHEN IT FIRST BUT
DEVONTE
BROKE, COURTESY OF
"THE NEW YORK POST."
THEY WILL LAUNCH INVESTIGATIONS
AND HEARINGS INTO HUNTER BIDEN.
THE CONTENTS OF THAT LAPTOP, AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY, WHO IS THE BIG
GUY THAT TONY BELINSKY,
HIS PRIVATE BUSINESS PARTNER,
SAID BENEFIT IN TERMS OF GETTING
10% OF POP DON'T PROFITS FROM
INFLUENCE PEDDLING IN PLACES
LIKE CHINA AND UKRAINE?
IS JOE BIDEN COMPROMISED BY
COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA AND
UKRAINE?
WE WILL FIND OUT PROBABLY EARLY
NEXT YEAR WHEN THOSE HEARINGS
LAUNCH, GUYS.
>> UNLESS I MISSED SOMETHING, I
DIDN'T KNOW HUNTER BIDEN WAS THE
FEDERAL EMPLOYEE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY OUR TAX DOLLARS
ARE GOING TO PAY FOR COVER FOR A
NONFEDERAL EMPLOYEE.
MAYBE THAT'S THE TOPIC OF JO'S
SECOND BOOK.
"C